we are now just over a fortnight away
from july the 19th the day on which the
government still seems determined to
remove
most remaining covert restrictions in
england
with 85 percent of other adults having
been given one dose of a vaccine and
nearly two-thirds having received
both doses the link between case numbers
and hospitalization
appears to have been broken or
has it well the pediatrician adam finn
is a member of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization
which advises the government on its
vaccines policy he joined us from
coimbra
in portugal um dr finn are we
on the on track for the end of lockdown
do you think
uh it's a really difficult question to
answer to be quite honest uh
the the rate of rise of cases is very
substantial at the moment
uh of course there is very clear
evidence that the vaccination program
has massively reduced the number of
hospitalizations and deaths but they are
nevertheless going up
right across the country um and that i
guess is the
the critical uh the critical factor that
determines whether or not uh
uh things can normalize um so yes
who knows i i guess uh we are in a very
uh unusual unprecedented situation and
uh
it's very tricky to give you a straight
answer well
um we heard from robert jenwick
the housing secretary a little earlier
some noises that
seem to suggest that we're heading in
that direction but um are you
sympathetic to the
bma's case that even if we do open up
there should be some restrictions for
example
the maintenance of mask discipline and
so on
well on a personal level i shall
certainly be continuing to wear a mask
if i've got any symptoms or if i'm in an
enclosed pace with
lots of other people for a prolonged
period of time indefinitely in fact
because i've learned that by doing that
i can reduce the risk of transmission of
all sorts
indefinitely yeah yeah absolutely i
think
we learned as pediatricians we learned
that we can avoid
massive problems with children getting
sick in the winter by doing these kind
of measures we simply didn't see the
epidemics of
respiratory viruses last winter that
we've seen every year
throughout my career so i i actually now
completely understand it
whereas i was puzzled before when i saw
asian people in the tube wearing
masks in the pre pandemic era so
i think mask wearing is is obviously
something we've learned
is extremely valuable to do under
certain circumstances that doesn't mean
i'll wear a mask all the time but it
does mean i will some of the time
well if we're thinking about return to
normality
once some of your scientific colleagues
worry that daily publication
of data on deaths and infections and
hospitalizations and so forth
are essentially panicking people rather
than reassuring them
do you think it's time to stop the
publication of that data at least with
that frequency
uh well i actually think that it's
important to share information with
people i think the moment you
stop doing that you run the risk of
people not trusting you anymore to
to explain uh the actions that you're
taking so certainly in the area where
i'm
involved in advising the government
which is around vaccination
we're very transparent with the data and
the evidence that we
use to to drive those recommendations
of course i think when you provide
information you need to explain it
it doesn't really make any sense to just
give numbers without
explaining what the implications are but
i'm not really in favor of suppressing
information no
the health secretary this morning is
saying that we need to learn to accept
covid and treat it essentially as the
same as
flu well each year according to
the ons we see
something like 20 22 000 deaths from
flu um do you accept
that that actually that is what we're
going to have to live with now it's
inevitable
uh it looks very likely that this
coronavirus like the others before it
will be with us
for the long term um i think in the
short term
exactly what it does and how much
trouble it causes around the world
looks pretty daunting uh in the longer
term i think it remains with us
and just how benign it becomes over time
is a matter of speculation
but but yes i don't think we're going to
see this virus disappear i think it's
going to join
all the others that cause trouble for us
every year
and we are going to have to learn to
live with it in the longer term yes
so more excess deaths would um the
i know you can't preempt jcvi decisions
but um do you expect therefore for
people
to uh receive a booster vaccination
to add to the regular flu vaccination
each year
well certainly we've made
recommendations in the last week to
uh if you like provide us a sense of
direction as to how a program like that
would look
and who would be targeted for boosters
if it proves necessary
i don't think it's absolutely uh 100
sure that we need to do that
but i think we need to be prepared for
the possibility uh particularly if we
begin to see signs of
waning vaccine protection or escape
from the protection that we've got from
the vaccines as the back as the virus
evolves
so we need to be ready to to do a
booster program if it if we need to
so you are worried about a fourth wave
or not worried about a fourth wave
okay you mean one after this one uh
i i think i'm most worried really about
the
the global situation uh there are
obviously countries where they're in
fourth and fifth waves now
and i'm worried about that not just out
of a sense of
um fairness for the people around the
world but actually also for us in the uk
uh we've had this experience in the last
two months
of importation of a much more infectious
virus
from india that will happen again if the
pandemic goes forward unchecked around
the world and will be left in
in a worse problem and i think that's
the most likely scenario to cause a
fourth or fifth wave
in this country that would be out of
control
adam finn thank you very much indeed